hey guys Ryan the right here damn the
cyber here we're gonna watch the
gameplay trailer I believe no story
trailer for dying light fact dying light
it's a zombie game and it looked cool it
looked cool it was like hardcore parkour
with guns with gun and zombies oh yeah I
remember the trailer now it was like
that really [ __ ] clever kills the
whole time don't block the light Rachel
you could take a photo but I'll block
the light
there's blood gore intense violence and
strong language that means they talk a
lot okay
you come to us like a snake in a glass
here in a city of lies the biggest liar
of the mold where am i internalized
can't you see you know my runners put
their lives in danger for guys like you
you follow their rules is stoked
listening as you follow mine but a man
who follows someone else's rules is no
Manito damn what in the [ __ ] right I'm
only out I couldn't watch or it's
shorter is the Sheila's foliot
humiliation you just doomed thousands of
innocent people
let's on clean [ __ ] I don't know if I
can fix this oh but I'm sure it's hoping
to try
for you a little to Dyson King not like
this not helpless can I trust you
that is the natural order of things can
kill or be killed
hate of being a don't know how much this
means dear boy to me to all of us
we are in over Italy
volcanoes are talking about phantom a
[ __ ]
we'll be a dog and save the dwellers of
the tower will you be a mammal by you
wanna scream
where are you Beauty someone else's
puppet
hmm so it's definitely more than just
killing zombies they got like a whole
bad guy thing going on here yeah as far
as story trailer goes it kind of is
going more walking deadish with like
giving us human villains during this
apocalypse happening well yeah I mean
like before zombie games and samba
movies it's always been about fighting
the zombies within the last like five
five like ten years or so it became more
about survival of finding other humans
because that's gonna happen they're
gonna have no rules we're gonna go back
to territorial business yeah we're the
[ __ ] tribal oh that's bad though that
is kind of racist what well you're
making fun of people who are tribal no
it was my time trying to just make you
look bad everyone calls me a racist
these days anybody anyway you invited I
mean the story still is it the clearest
to me I don't know I mean it looks cool
I love the tone of it like the graphics
are not like that the most mind-blowing
but I like that I mean with the cool
music backing it up you get a cool kind
of Menace about it yeah the colors are
still very kind of muted they're very a
crowd scene it feels like a brightened
walking-dead story yeah like a Russian
guy what was that guy I I think it's all
nationalities yeah this is like big a
grab bag it got a little America little
rush yeah some of the voice-over acting
sounds a little cheesy though a little
over-the-top
answer me [ __ ] I couldn't help
but laugh and I'm like that supposed to
sound badass but yeah it sounded a
little bit goofy I'm sure in the moment
maybe it's a little better
hopefully a foot but I did like how they
establish that he does parkour I was
like okay cool
there actually gave it an explanation
for how this guy can move like this also
there was a crowbar in the trailer there
for half-life 3 confirmed yes I know
what he's talking about I know he's some
people will get it yeah comment down
below if you got it anyway guys they
should telling me that trailer was out
if you're new to this chanel you can
subscribe to so real or reject those and
you could check out Dan's gaming channel
that cyber tow chanel oh it's really
[ __ ] cool there's got a lot of
gameplays on there I'm in a few videos a
lot of the gameplays yeah
you'll have a good time you'll have a
good time no alcohol required but when
it is there it's better the only way to
enjoy my videos is drunk get drunk or
stoned not sure that's me I know this
Jesus Jesus had nothing to do with it
but he did bring the wine to the party
oh oh that's what I did
tight in Christian fate Roy Diaz since
I'm first to comment man I have a
shout-out please sure Roy Diaz I mean
it's a little bit easier than trying to
be the first to comment but sure you
know that song I love Roy Roy Roy Roy
Roy Roy Roy can rely commercial Oh God
that the Starbucks commercial Roy like
oh my god it was so bad I wanted to
gouge my eyes out pierce my ear drums
really I masturbated to it yes hoarse
you - of course you I didn't even need
it in front of me I just played in my
head and I masturbated to the tune
Roy Roy Roy Roy could you shut up man
every time God upon my shoutouts if you
want a shout-out say something
interesting fun informative or whatever
facebook.com slash the real reject shout
outs cyber doubt it's my catchphrase my
catchphrase say dad [ __ ] off my couch
button click on my dick to subscribe
said click on this button buy my dick to
subscribe
if you fire you